[Aplausos]
[Música]
a menudo han liado los chinos queridos
amigos y amigas de visual política no
hace falta que os lo diga china está en
el ojo del huracán últimamente por un
motivo o por otro incluso cuando no es
culpa suya este país no deja de causar
los grandes quebraderos de cabeza si en
2019 fue la guerra comercial y sus
tensas relaciones con trump en 2020 la
aparición del sars coronavirus 2
popularmente conocido por el nombre de
la enfermedad de causa cobit 19 se lleva
la palma y no es para menos hasta el
momento de preparar este vídeo este
virus ha infectado a más de 200.000
personas en 167 países diferentes fijaos
si es serio este asunto que por primera
vez muchos países están cerrando sus
fronteras y bajando las persianas
calicanto sin ir más lejos aquí en
españa estamos en cuarentena
[Música]
obligatoriamente tenemos que quedarnos
en casa tras haber decretado el gobierno
el estado de alarma si sales a la calle
tienes que hacerlo solo y con un motivo
justificado porque literalmente si no es
así te pueden multar o incluso arrestar
en caso de que te resistas
y no se trata sólo del caso de españa en
italia y francia entre otros países
están también en una situación similar
cuarentenas obligatorias comercios
cerrados fábricas paradas no hay
procedentes de un caos semejante ahora
bien qué es lo que hace que este virus
sea tan serio que es exactamente a lo
que nos estamos enfrentando
[Música]
el sars coronavirus 2 es un nuevo con
una virus detectado por primera vez en
la ciudad china de wuhan y se trata no
del primero ni segundo ni tercero sino
del séptimo coronavirus humano que se
conoce hasta la fecha que es que los
coronavirus no son para nada algo nuevo
de hecho precisamente alguno de estos 7
coronavirus conocidos son la causa del
resfriado común en general son virus que
pueden generar enfermedades con
sintomatología es muy leves pero que sin
embargo hay un pequeño grupo de ellos
que no son tan simpáticos por ejemplo el
síndrome respiratorio de oriente medio'
mercy en una letalidad del 34 por ciento
síndrome respiratorio agudo grave sars
alcanza una letalidad de en torno a un
9% y ahora también está este el sars
coronavirus 2 está por ver qué letalidad
causa pero que se cree que puede ser
superior al 3%
[Música]
y es que amigos el coronavirus que ahora
en estos momentos azota con rabia al
mundo entero parece ser una versión más
resistente contagiosa y algo menos letal
que su hermanastro el sars veréis los
primeros casos de contagio por éste
coronavirus se detectaron originalmente
en el mercado de marisco de juanan en
luján entre los días 8 y 18 de diciembre
de 2019 sin embargo las investigaciones
retrospectivas posteriores señalan que
el paciente 1 es decir el primer
infectado identificado podría tratar de
bastante antes fijaos coronavirus el
primer caso confirmado en china de kobe
19 se remonta el 17 de noviembre y si es
evidente que a medida que haya nuevas
investigaciones es muy probable que el
paciente uno puede cambiar a otro
todavía anterior y es que tal y como os
podéis imaginar resulta extremadamente
complicado identificar un nuevo virus y
reaccionar a tiempo porque claro
pensando un momento si no tienes ni
pajolera idea de que ese virus existe y
de repente pues aparecen pacientes con
síntomas que en muchos casos puede
y ser parecidos a los de una gripe cómo
demonios vas a activar ningún mecanismo
de alarma
esos días son días en los que la gente
se transmite la enfermedad sin que nadie
se dé cuenta ni sepa ni siquiera que
existe un virus nuevo
es decir es una situación muchísimo más
compleja que la de un país al que ya le
llega el virus una vez ya está
identificado y localizado ahora bien
teniendo todo esto en cuenta queréis
saber cómo fueron los primeros días de
la epidemia en china qué pensáis pensáis
que lo gestionaron bien o que lo
gestionaron mal pues atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el principio del caos
amigos amigas de visual político desde
mediados de diciembre del 2019 en la
ciudad china de wuhan empezaron a llegar
a los hospitales pacientes con neumonía
no identificadas
es decir que los médicos por más pruebas
que hacían no conseguían entender por
qué diablos de repente varias personas
habían desarrollado afecciones
respiratorias severas
no había explicación porque simplemente
no estaban contagiadas por ningún virus
conocido y las pruebas que se hacían
intentando buscar un sentido a todos
esos síntomas
avan siempre negativo hasta que por fin
a finales de diciembre se logró tras
muchas pruebas identificar a un nuevo
patógeno un nuevo con una virus llamado
nuevo con una virus 2019
pero un momento si pensabais que china
se puso desde el minuto 1 - a la obra
para luchar contra este virus proteger a
la población y ser transparentes con la
información estáis muy pero que muy
equivocados de hecho fue más bien todo
lo contrario
[Música]
en un primer momento el régimen chino
intentó mantener un silencio informativo
absoluto sobre la aparición del nuevo
coronavirus tanto es así que varios días
después de que china lograse en un
laboratorio identificar que lo que en
realidad estaban experimentando era la
explosión de toda una epidemia por este
nuevo virus los hospitales y los equipos
médicos seguían sin tener ni idea de lo
que ocurría allí está por ejemplo el
caso del doctor li wei liang este médico
escribió a sus colegas el 30 de
diciembre de 2019 a través de wii chat
el whatsapp chino contándoles que a su
hospital habían llegado siete pacientes
con neumonías de origen desconocido muy
parecidas a las que producía el
coronavirus srs
y es que amigos el sars es un viejo
conocido en china desde el 2002 y
durante más de dos años ese coronavirus
causó una epidemia en más de dos docenas
de países por ese motivo seguramente el
doctor lee pensó que se podía tratar de
un nuevo brote sin embargo como ahora
sabemos la realidad era muy diferente lo
que el doctor lee tal vez nunca podría
haber imaginado es que estaba ante el
comienzo de la peor crisis sanitaria del
mundo moderno una pandemia global
causada por un nuevo virus que el
gobierno chino ya había identificado
hacía días
el caso es que por algún incomprensible
motivo ya sabéis todos como son las
dictaduras y empezó a resultarle molestó
a las autoridades de wuhan y tan sólo
tres días después de alertar a varios
médicos sobre el tema recibió la visita
de un par de agentes de la oficina de
seguridad pública amenazándole con
represalias porque literalmente esparcir
informaciones falsas en internet ya
sabéis fake news
incluso le hicieron firmar una carta
donde venía a reconocer sus presuntas
fechorías por desgracia el doctor lee
termino infectándose por coronavirus y
el día 7 de febrero fallecía en un
hospital chino el caso es que los días
pasaban los casos que decían y crecían y
chinas seguía sin decir absolutamente
nada ni una palabra es decir la primera
reacción de las autoridades fue simple y
llanamente esconder la verdad y mirar
hacia otro lado esperando que el
temporal amainara pero por supuesto la
ocultación de la verdad no frena la
propagación del virus
[Música]
durante las primeras semanas del 2020 el
silencio y las mentiras informativas
fueron la tónica habitual a pesar de que
la epidemia continuaba creciendo a toda
velocidad y la pregunta es cómo es
posible tanta negligencia pues veréis os
lo hemos contado alguna que otra vez
aquí en visual político normalmente los
líderes provinciales en china tienen un
ansia tro de ascender a la política
estatal y para lograrlo deben demostrar
competencias de gestión ejemplares en
sus provincias y claro
acaso penséis que una epidemia
descontrolada es la mejor carta de
presentación para pedir un billete de
avión a pekín en otras palabras la
propia carrera política de los líderes
municipales y regionales estaba en
peligro tal vez por eso las autoridades
provinciales de jubilación that de buján
intentaron desesperadamente taparlo todo
o mentir y tratar de controlar la
situación por sí mismos sin que el
gobierno central metiera la mano
seguro que los que hayáis visto hace
poco la serie de chernóbil os suena todo
esto algo verdad por supuesto todo eso
era mentira
ahora bien porque fue este un terrible y
salvaje error que definieron lo que iba
a venir después
pues veréis el caso es que los
contagiados asintomáticos o con síntomas
muy leves fueron clave en el crecimiento
inicial de la epidemia tal y como
explicó la revista science
sin saberlo sin tener la más remota
sospecha estos contagiados a
sintomáticos expandieron la enfermedad y
multiplicaron los contagios sustanciales
infecciones no documentadas facilitan la
rápida diseminación del nuevo
coronavirus de esta forma en apenas unos
pocos días en luján y juvenil las cosas
se desmadraron y a las autoridades
sanitarias no les quedó otra que decir
la verdad
en apenas tres días desde que dijeran
que todo estaba bajo control los
contagios se habían multiplicado
prácticamente por cinco había empezado
un caos que llevaría semanas meses
controlar
finalmente el día 20 de enero china
aceptó por fin que el virus se transmite
entre personas fue entonces cuando dio
comienzo la batalla para frenarlo
tan solo tres días más tarde la ciudad
de luján ya estaba bajo una cuarentena
estricta algo que poco después se
expandió a toda la provincia de hubei
una provincia que atentos unos 60
millones de habitantes
y así amigos es cómo empezó un verdadero
infierno para los habitantes de juve y
el infierno causado por un virus que
estuvo tres semanas campando a sus
anchas sin ningún control por culpa del
secretismo y el oscurantismo de la clase
política china
pero ahora bien una vez asumida la
verdad que podía que que se podía hacer
para detener la epidemia cómo se
comportaron las autoridades chinas desde
el momento en el que se vieron forzadas
a reconocer la verdad qué medidas
tomaron y tal vez la pregunta más
importante de todas cuáles han sido las
consecuencias atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la dura lucha
[Música]
queridos amigos queridas amigas de
visual política durante finales del mes
de enero y comienzos de febrero sheen
experimentó un auténtico tormento
[Música]
desde el punto de vista económico del
cual ya os hablaremos en profundidad en
un próximo vídeo así que ya sabéis
suscribiros al canal la actividad de las
principales ciudades se paralizó y la
producción industrial cayó a niveles
inferiores incluso a los registrados
durante la crisis financiera del 2008 se
dice poco
[Música]
pero sin duda alguna lo peor se lo llevó
la provincia de jubail epicentro del
brote allí el gobierno chino establecí
más medidas de bloqueo y cuarentenas
salvajes nunca antes vistas para así
maximizar el distanciamiento social
aislar al virus y evitar nuevos
contagios
en otras palabras evitar que las
personas se acercasen unas a otras
las autoridades chinas bloquearon
carreteras se prohibieron los viajes
interurbanos se levantaron barreras
físicas dentro de los núcleos urbanos de
la provincia de hebei para evitar que la
gente fuera de un lugar a otro se
establecieron permisos por escrito para
salir de casa en los que tenías que
justificar porque lo hacías y se
pusieron en marcha servicios de reparto
de comida a domicilio para que la gente
ni siquiera tuviera que salir al
supermercado
y eso no es todo también se habilitaron
todo tipo de espacios para acoger a las
personas contagiadas se llevaron a cabo
miles de controles en la vía pública
para detectar posibles casos e incluso
más de 7000 personas trabajaron a toda
pastilla mañana tarde y noche en la
construcción de nuevos hospitales
hospitales que estuvieron listos en
apenas unos pocos días y que permitieron
habilitar un montón de nuevas camas para
hacer frente a la epidemia
[Música]
es decir desde que china aceptó por fin
el problema la respuesta fue muy
enérgica y estricta hicieron todo lo
posible para frenar la epidemia aunque
ello supusiera un duro golpe económico
y llegados a este punto la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es surtieron efecto
todas estas medidas pues las cifras
indican que si así fue
[Música]
tan solo en la segunda mitad de enero se
redujo la r 0 es decir la tasa de
contagios de 235 a 105 es decir en menos
de medio mes el número de personas
contagiadas por cada caso positivo cayó
a más de la mitad el aislamiento surtido
efecto
así de esta forma el ritmo de nuevos
contagios sea plano y a principios de
febrero empezarán a decrecer los nuevos
casos de contagio
[Música]
pero puede que a estas alturas muchos os
estaréis preguntando a ver cuál habría
sido el escenario si no se hubieran
tomado medidas tan radicales pues bien
amigos agarraos bien a la silla
varios modelos epidemiológicos han
estimado que se hubiera infectado el 40
por ciento de la población de china si
no hubieran tomado estas medidas es
decir estamos hablando de unos 500
millones de personas
[Música]
ahora bien un momento no cantemos
victoria tan rápido es cierto se
evitaron millones de contagios y se
controló la epidemia pero esos mismos
estudios determinan que si china hubiera
actuado tres semanas antes debe ocultar
la realidad como hizo se podría haber
reducido muchísimo el número de
contagios hecho se estima que a menos
del 5 por ciento de los que finalmente
hubo
y por supuesto las consecuencias para el
resto del mundo probablemente hubieran
sido también muy diferentes la expansión
del virus no se hubiera producido o
hubiera sido mínima
con lo cual realmente podemos decir que
china ha hecho bien las cosas podemos
hablar de éxito pues sí y no depender
por una parte cometieron una enorme
negligencia ocultando la informalidad y
no actuando durante tantísimos días y no
eso no se lo podemos pasar por alto al
gobierno chino pero por otra parte es
verdad que las medidas radicales de
cuarentena que tomaron frenaron la
epidemia en seco hasta el punto de que
por ejemplo en el momento en el que
hemos terminado de preparar este vídeo
el 17 de marzo china ha reportado sólo
13 nuevos casos de los cuales atentos 12
han sido importados del extranjero si lo
habéis escuchado bien un solo caso local
en un país que llegó a reportar más de
5000 casos locales en un día he visto
cómo están las cosas por el mundo eso
parece un éxito pero claro la propia
respuesta radical china fue la
consecuencia de la propia negligencia
del sistema político chino la
negligencia que está esparciendo el caos
y el número de víctimas a lo largo y
ancho de todo el mundo pero ahora turno
para ti que piensas que es que china
merece alabanzas por su gestión de la
crisis o por contra crees que las
autoridades chinas son las responsables
de todo
ha ocurrido y dándole otra vuelta de
tuerca creéis que la respuesta de las
autoridades de pekín sería viable en un
país democrático tendrían consecuencias
comportamientos similares no tenemos una
situación en españa en la que a nivel de
país se pueda pensar en una transmisión
generalizada es controlada ni muchísimo
menos buenas tardes estimados
compatriotas en el día de hoy acabo de
comunicar al jefe del estado la
celebración mañana de un consejo de
ministros extraordinario para decretar
el estado de alarma en todo nuestro país
en toda españa' amigos dejar vuestras
opiniones de los comentarios y por
supuesto ya sabéis si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like suscribiros al casal
político y darle a la campanita para no
perderte ninguna de nuestras próximas
novedades un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]